in our last episode we discussed the
psychology of grit and how leaders and
enterprises can be built to withstand
crisis so we thought it was the perfect
time to revisit an interview from one of
our very first episodes in this master
class we'll hear from stanford graduate
school of business professor baba shiv
whose research focuses on the
neuroscience of decision making and the
practice of innovation from silicon
valley to emerging markets one thing
you've got to recognize is that at the
end of the day most human decisions and
most human behaviors are grounded in
emotion
it is not the rational brain
in his experience surveying hundreds of
ceos over the years professor shiv has
seen companies deal with all sorts of
crises some have flourished but some
have folded
in this deep dive we'll discuss what
distinguishes the survivors the mental
and physical ways that leaders can
prepare to innovate during crises
and some distinct advantages shared by
entrepreneurs in emerging markets when a
crisis hits
[Music]
i'm darius teeter and this is a master
class by gritten growth with stanford
graduate school of business the show
where africa and south asia's intrepid
entrepreneurs share their trials and
triumphs
[Music]
much of professor shiv's work is focused
on the difference between what he calls
the type 1 and type 2 mindsets i'll let
him explain
if you have read danny kahneman's work
thinking fast and slow then exactly what
he says that most of our decisions are
made by fast thinking systems what i
call emotional systems not by slow
thinking deliberative systems
we've got to understand how does the
emotional brain work
the way the emotional brain is geared to
behave at any given point in time will
depend upon the mindset that prevails on
the mental state that prevents at that
point in time is it a type one mindset
or is it a type two mindset
so these are terms that are borrowed
from statistics and statistics we have
the notion of the type one error and the
type two error what is the type of
neuron statistics the fear of making a
mistake it's a fear of failure
the type two mindset on the hand is not
a fear of failure
it's a fear of missing out on
opportunities at the end of the day is
really not a fear it is a desire for new
opportunities and it turns out that the
brain has two distinct neural
circuitries one devoted to the
risk-averse type one mindset and another
devoted to the risk starter and type two
mindset and the most critical thing
about the way the emotional brain is
geared to behave at any given point in
time is that if the brain is still in a
state of stress
in other words still in a type 1 mindset
the brain will be unable to switch to
the risk tolerant type 2 mindset and
that's why it's so crucial that you
first get into a state of comfort this
could be for individuals could be in the
form of getting good night's sleep
fitness also makes a big difference
practices like meditation etc makes a
big difference because it's going to
make the brain a lot more resilient to
stress which means that the leader is
not often stressed which means the
leader's brain can switch into the risk
tolerant type 2 mindset and there's a
lot of research backing this up that
something like 90 to 95 of human
decisions and behaviors are shaped
non-consciously by emotional brain
systems not by rational brain systems
so in babashi's lexicon the type 1
mindset worries about failure while the
type 2 mindset is open to opportunities
i wondered how these mindsets actually
affect decision making
at the end of the day what the rational
brain is good at is simply
rationalizing
what the emotional brain has already
decided to do which means if you're
stuck in a risk-averse mindset the
rational brain will come in and say
these are the reasons why you have to be
risk averse these are the reasons why
you should not innovate etc
whereas if you're in type 2 mindset the
rational brain will come in and say here
are the reasons why you should take some
chances
and then you can start thinking about
the downstream applications of the
simple principle of the emotional brain
having the type 1 circuitry and the type
2 circuitry you'll see some leaders when
the crisis hits
they would have done all the scenario
planning beforehand they might have plan
b plan c etc but that is really very
cognitive in nature that exercise it is
when they get into the crisis when the
true leadership capabilities will begin
to emerge and you can see that happening
among leaders that when the crisis hits
they're able to kind of take a step back
they're able to assess the situation and
then think very creatively about what
can i do
to address the challenge but even more
important how can i leverage the
opportunities that this crisis has
afforded
of course the mind is part of the body
and our mindset is affected by our
physical condition
so what can we do to achieve a type 2
mindset
here's what baba shiv recommends
how should a leader go about managing a
crisis first and foremost the person
needs to calm down first thing i would
advise the leaders to do is get good
sleep
what tends to happen during crises is
that leaders are fighting a lot of fires
and what they would sacrifice is sleep
and
lack of sleep is a huge detriment
because what will happen is that if
you're not had enough sleep what is
called restorative sleep when all the
brain chemicals like serotonin dopamine
etc are coming back to normal you're
going to naturally from a physiological
and a brain standpoint you're naturally
going to wake up being in a risk-averse
type 1 mindset that's the last thing
that the ruler wants to do in times of
crisis so get good night's rest if you
can let your team do that do that as
well because what is needed out here is
not just the leader but also the entire
team that is on board to kind of
wade through the crisis addressing the
challenges but more importantly grabbing
the opportunities that the crisis is
going to be affected
[Music]
the second thing that i would do is that
even before any crisis hits a leader
should prac get into practices like
meditation yoga tai chi etc now this
might sound like some kind of yoga
master kind of teaching you know there's
a lot of science behind this suggesting
that
if you engage in practices like tai chi
yoga meditation etc that slows down your
breathing your brain is going to become
a lot more resilient to stress
so when a crisis hits get good night's
sleep and if you're not yet practicing
the leader is not practicing meditation
tai chi yoga et cetera slowing down
their breath they should start that
practice
just to make sure that the brain is able
to go into the innovative or the type 2
risk tolerant mindset
there are even ways to physically
measure how prepared your mind is to
deal with stress
so technology is going to definitely
help us going forward right i mean so if
you think about
how resilient your brain is to stress
is highly correlated with what is
referred to as heart rate variability
heart rate variability essentially taps
into the parasympathetic nervous system
so we have the sympathetic nervous
system and the parasympathetic the
sympathetic is the fight flight system
and the sympathetic parasympathetic is
the rest digest system calm down calm
down etc if you want to know if your
brain is inherently resilient to stress
you can easily monitor your heart rate
variability there are a lot of ways of
doing that you can do this with your
phone there are other ones that are out
there you can measure your heart rate
variability and the heart rate
variability essentially is the following
the heart doesn't beat like a metronome
we think that it is beating at regular
intervals it is not
there is always a fluctuation between
beats so it is called beat to beat
interval the b b2b interval will always
have a fluctuation
the greater the fluctuation the greater
the variability
in other words greater the heart rate
variability the more resilient the brain
is to stress
so one of the things that a leader could
do thanks to technology is to monitor
their heart rate variability at any
given point in time which will tell them
are they in a position right now to make
a decision an important decision
[Music]
many leaders in times of crisis fall
back on tried and true products
customers and markets they go with what
they know or they take a wait and see
approach
that may seem reasonable but is it right
so let's think about it why is crisis
the best time to innovate
it is charles darwin who said that it is
not the strongest of the species that
survives
not even the most intelligence the one
that is going to survive is the one that
is most adaptable to change
which means that yes you can say as a
leader i'll just wait this out
you know for six months
fine i'm going to emerge from there
maybe i'll emerge weaker but i'll kind
of
start from that point in time and move
forward
but keep in mind you're not alone in the
market there are other players in the
market and if there's another player in
the market who as
darwin said is much more adaptable to
the change they're going to emerge much
stronger than you are going into the
future so don't assume that your
strength before the crisis is going to
remain the same going forward because
there are other players out there who
are probably being doing the right kind
of things in terms of being innovative
adaptive et cetera are going to be much
much stronger
so the survival of the company in the
long haul
never ever comes from sticking to the
status quo
it always will come from being adaptable
to change responding to change that is
happening and that is where the leader
needs to have an innovation mindset and
the organization as a culture needs to
have an innovation mindset
what they would do is that they always
treat the situation as being dynamic it
is not static what it means is that you
have come into the situation with a lot
of assumptions preconceived notions etc
that's the same thing for leaders as
well crisis is a great opportunity for
leaders to come in and reassess all the
assumptions and preconceived notions
that they have
don't try to do what you are doing in
the past because that is not going to
help you address the crisis
because you cannot assume that the world
is static anymore a crisis is going to
be very dynamic
[Music]
baba shiv has a simple shorthand for
leaders who bring an innovation mindset
to a crisis
innovation equals creativity times
execution and divided by constraints
and no that's not a mathematical formula
but for baba it does add up
generally if i if you should ask people
or what comes to mind when the word
innovation is uttered in general people
will say innovation is creativity
innovation is really not just creativity
creativity is an important component of
that that requires the innovation
mindset the type 2 mindset etc but it
also requires execution
you are coming up with certain
hypotheses that need to be tested and
that requires execution
the third component here is constraints
so the way i look at this is that
innovation is creativity multiplied by
execution divided by perceived
constraints all the constraints out
there the second way to think about
constraints is that and i've seen this
happening time and time and time again
if i tell you to come up with a solution
so for example you're going to rwanda
you're looking at a little home out
there the integrity of the flooring in
the home is not great and if i'm going
to tell you you need to come up with a
solution for this your first thing that
you would do is to say okay i'll just
make sure i'll just find out how much it
costs to put cement and so on and so
forth not realizing that person will not
be able to spend more than twenty
dollars for the floor
that is a constraint
so if you bring in constraints very
early on in the design process as you're
figuring out what is working what is not
working what are the assumptions to be
made what are the hypotheses etc it is
always a good idea to bring in the
constraints
so two things quickly to summarize about
this equation that innovation is
creativity multiplied by execution yes
creativity is important
yes execution is important but let's not
forget the constraints and especially in
a crisis situation you're bound to face
constraints that are never faced before
it could be financial constraints it
could be market constraints it could be
team constraints maybe a team member has
fallen sick a critical team member has
fallen sick those are all constraints
and innovation comes from being able to
develop your solution and deliver on
your solution
subject to these constraints
always a good idea to incorporate
constraints into the design process
babashiv has seen firsthand that leaders
from emerging markets are particularly
resourceful not in spite of their
situations but because of them
what i noticed about the entrepreneurs
who come out from india africa being
east africa west africa or southern
africa one thing i noticed is that they
are extremely innovative extremely
innovative because they are facing
constraints all the time
there could be credit constraints
interest rates are very high there is a
lack of trust between the supplier and
the thing they're dealing with all the
time
and i feel that rather than saying that
that is a disadvantage of being an
entrepreneur developing economy i would
argue it is actually an advantage
because inherently you are a lot more
innovative in terms of the creativity in
terms of the execution and going with
the constraints that are out there
you're far better equipped to handle
crises than someone who is probably in
the more western more developed kind of
economies and also one of the things
that they quickly realize in these
developing economies is that
because of all the constraints because
of all the struggles they have to go
through
when given an opportunity to collaborate
with other business leaders they jump
onto that opportunity much sooner than
people in more developed economies would
do because in developed records you can
say yeah i kind of raise more money and
i can solve the problem yeah i can hire
more people i can solve the problem yeah
i can pay more and pay less give a
discount i can solve the problem
the business leaders in many of the
developing economies that i have
encountered out there don't go with that
kind of assumption it's not the first
thing is not going to raise more money
is that who can i reach out to in my
network so that i can get some help
and that it's a very natural process
that they go through which is why you're
seeing now we're seeing this right in
front of our eyes as we speak
all the collaboration that is happening
among uh the business leaders who have
attended the seed program
part of what makes a crisis such a
fertile time for innovation is that it
turns the world on its head
if you go with that assumption that the
world is dynamic
what that allows you to do is first get
rid of preconceived notions and start
looking at what new assumptions i have
to make going forward and how do i go
about testing those assumptions it's one
thing to simply go about coming up with
with new assumptions out there the other
thing is to actually execute on that
which means you need to test these
things out so i would always advocate a
leader during a crisis
to consider the situation to be dynamic
even more so when we are not in a crisis
situation
go back to the drawing board and ask the
fundamental questions is that what
assumptions have i come into the
situation with
that is all assumptions that have come
from the past
what assumptions need to be relaxed what
new assumptions or hypotheses need to be
formed ask yourself what is the business
that you're in and very often i see
entrepreneurs making the mistake they'll
say that i'm in the business of selling
pineapple juice
no you're not in the business of selling
pineapple juice you're in the business
of quenching thirst
with a beverage that tastes good and is
also healthy and is also nutritious
okay so if that is how you define your
business why rely on pineapple i might
find a local fruit
in the in the country where i can
utilize my same production facility to
create a beverage that is no longer
dependent upon pineapples
if it works then how do you replicate
that if it doesn't work that's fine you
at least learned you you've failed fast
you feel cheap and you have failed
forward in the sense that you learned
something from the situation that you
can now apply to the crisis situation
going forward
[Music]
it is in times of crisis that the true
metal of a leader
is going to be determined and which is
why
if you go to a vc and you are a startup
your startup failed you go to for the
next venture you go and knock at the
door of a vc and say i want to raise
money the vc is not going to say oh the
last business you started and you failed
what they're going to say is that you
learnt a lot from what the failure that
you went through which means you're
going to be a lot more mature which
means you're not going to repeat the
same mistakes that you committed in the
previous startup
part of innovation is messing up
but in many cultures the fear of failure
can stifle experimentation
2007 2008 time period the department of
science technology in india had asked me
to come down do some work with them
about how do we foster entrepreneurship
in india i started talking to some of
the best students from the best
universities most of them engineering
schools in india and i was shocked to
learn that the top 10 of the class
irrespective of the university i went to
and i asked these students
you want to intervene you want to become
an author but let me ask you a question
you can either be an innovator or you
can be an entrepreneur and that's a big
difference out there you can innovate
stuff and then sell off the ip to
someone else entrepreneur requires you
actually have to run a company and i
asked every one of these these students
that i met up
would you like to be an entrepreneur and
invariably this is 2007 time period they
said no
and asked why
and that's why you've got to understand
the culture of the place imagine that a
young kid in an engineering school okay
32 years old has a job offer from the
tatas
the person cannot make career decisions
on
on their own that's the culture of of
india and many of the asian countries
and also countries in africa by the way
where if i have to make these career
decisions i have to consult my parents
i have to consult my uncle my aunts and
so on and so forth there are multiple
people out there if i'm this young
person going to my parents and saying i
have a job offer from the tatas
but i want to go into entrepreneurship
what do you think the parents are going
to say they're going to say you are
stupid this is how i brought you up and
therefore when you're designing these
solutions you got to be acutely aware of
the cultural context that we are
operating in and you're and it's
absolutely right that in most cultures
out there
failure is not tolerated failure is
ridiculed sometimes even punished
right that's that's kind of state out
there
hopefully what the graduate school of
business is doing because that is the
mission of the graduate school of
business is to change lives change
organizations change the world
is for us to create these ecosystems
where failure is no longer going to be
seen as double yes it is going to take
time
but the hope is that within one
generation 20 years that we think about
these developing economies where this
culture of failure or against failure is
so deeply embedded
will begin to change and we're beginning
to see the change i mean from 2007 to
there was a massive change in what i was
observing on the ground in india
where now young kids in the top 10
of their class
they don't want to go and work for a
large corporation which is no different
than the stanford gsb
they want to work in a startup either an
early state or a growth stage startup
why because that taboo has disappeared
and why has that happened that's because
now there are role models
there are people who started companies
like flipkart in india etc who become
very successful now the parents are
saying yeah you have an offer from the
tatas but i don't want you to go and
work in the tatas out there that is for
the previous generation i would rather
you go and start a company and make it
into the next flipkart of the world
[Music]
baba has outlined a series of steps for
a leader to get in the right mindset to
tackle crises from challenging
assumptions while recognizing
constraints to searching for
opportunities to innovate and embracing
failure
but i wondered
how does a leader bring their team along
how do they foster a type 2 mindset
throughout the organization
if everyone is stressed
generally what tends to happen is people
will go into their own shell
because it's a survival mode i have to
survive first before i start helping
others and start collaborating with
others
it is the leader's job to kind of say
let us go through this whole thing
forget about whether you win or lose
ask yourself the question
are you going to feel proud with
yourself of what you did and you're
going to feel proud when you're giving
your best
and that's the leader's job the leader's
job is to have the internal team members
get out of the state of stress knowing
that our survival is going to come from
teamwork
and the second critical factor that they
have to be looking at the leaders are to
be doing is
for the team members to kind of
put in place the culture and the space
out there
so that they can start now reaching out
and collaborating among one another one
another and that is the leader's job the
leaders job is to tell the the staff out
there that it is not about losing it's
not about winning out there but let us
feel proud and let us be proud in such a
way that when we emerge from the crisis
we would have emerged much stronger not
the company not the leader but all of us
collectively have emerged from it
feeling much stronger failures could
have happened that's okay
one thing we've learned over the past 18
months is that big exogenous shocks like
the pandemic are experienced not just as
a crisis for each company
but as a series of interrelated and
sometimes reinforcing crises throughout
supply chains and markets
so focusing all your energy internally
may be a missed opportunity
i asked baba how leaders can draw in
external resources in crisis do leaders
have potential allies with shared
interests
people often talk about competitive
advantage and don't get me wrong that is
important in other words how is your
value proposition superior to that of
your nearest competitor that's
comparative advantage but people forget
that there is a second element which is
referred to as collaborative advantage
now
collaborative advantage very often is
about how do you manage your
dependencies
so you might have suppliers out there
you have customers out there your
distributors out there these are all
relationships what do we often end up
doing in trying to create a
collaborative advantage
we adopt a transactional approach the
transaction approach being that we're
going to sign some contracts if there's
any violation of the contracts then we
can go to the court of law and have that
adjudicated and so on and so forth but
guess what in a transactional approach
will give rise to a lot of suspicion
people are suspecting one another
they're not divulging information with
one another it's an adversarial kind of
a relationship
the true collaborative advantage comes
when one adopts a relational approach
not a transaction of a relational
approach and if you go to many of the
asian countries you kind of notice that
go to japan for example
you will never be able to break into the
japanese market unless you have created
a very strong deep relationship with the
key partner that you're looking for in
japan because everything is based on
relationship and at the core of
relationship
the relationship approach to creating
collaborative advantage is building
trust
it is in times of crisis when everyone
is struggling it's not just you you're
not alone in this there are other people
also who are struggling out there
how do we go to these important
strategic partners your suppliers your
distributors etc not with a
transactional approach and guess what
when you adopt that kind of relational
approach that your partner has also been
doing
people will feel grateful for that
they will always remember you that in
times of difficulty when even your
partner didn't have the money to pay
salaries etc
that leader was able to do something to
help people out and people never forget
that never ever forget that and you're
going to develop a deep level
relationship
not only amongst your team members and
your partner is doing the right thing
they're developing that kind of
camaraderie to emerge other prices but
even your strategic partners out there
your suppliers your distributors are
going to kind of look at you very
differently that you're not just here
for a transactional game but it's just
an exchange that is taking place but
you're here for a collaborative game
where all of us are going to win
i asked baba shiv to summarize some
actionable takeaways for ceos facing a
crisis
so let me give some thoughts here
for any leader who is going through a
crisis okay
first one
remember that
you are in a unique position to not only
survive but emerge from the crisis being
stronger
and you have the capabilities to do that
and if you don't you got to build it
the second one that i would say is
always think about not just compared to
advantage think also about collaborative
advantage
and think about collaborative advantage
that comes not from just a transactional
approach comes from a relational
approach
and what that means is building
meaningful connections that are grounded
in trust
if you're already in a crisis right now
hopefully you have prepared for the
crisis so keep in mind that
the people who are better prepared are
going to be the winners
but you can't prepare for every single
crisis so preparation is not just about
scenario planning preparation is not
just about thinking about various
strategies and outcomes and so on
preparation comes from the fact that do
i have the capabilities which is the
emotional capabilities
to deal with the crisis number one and
number two does my team
have the capabilities the emotional
capabilities to be innovative
at times of crisis
and the third takeaway is that it is a
leader's job to make sure
that the organization is adaptable to
change and it's a leader's job to ensure
that that organization emerges from the
crisis a lot stronger than before and at
the root of that
is an innovation mindset
[Music]
babashiv believes companies that take
these steps are better positioned to win
in the future if you think about the
success long-term success of any
organization
in my humble opinion that is going to
come from
times of crisis like this
and you this is universal
but what these leaders would kind of
learn from this is the importance of
maintaining connections with one another
meaningful connections with one another
and creating a collaborative advantage
that is truly grounded in meaningful
connections truly grounded in trust
rather than a transactional approach
so i believe that this
period that we are in
where the leaders from africa from india
etc are innovating
i think is going to pay off huge in
terms of long term because what we're
going to observe from this crisis is
success stories and these are not
short-term success stories these are
going to be long-term success stories
i want to thank professor shiv for
sharing his insights on how to prepare
our bodies and minds to lead through
crisis and for encouraging entrepreneurs
across the world to work together in
these difficult times
[Music]
this has been a master class for britain
growth with stanford graduate school of
business and i'm your host darius teeter
in an upcoming episode we will hear from
matt abrahams a stanford lecturer and
the host of the popular podcast think
fast talk smart
matt will share invaluable advice for
how to communicate your big idea i hope
you'll join us
if you want to find out more about how
stanford graduate school of business is
partnering with entrepreneurs throughout
africa and south asia through stanford
seed visit us at seed.stanford.edu
podcast if you like this episode don't
forget to hit follow and share it with a
friend written growth is a podcast by
stanford seed lori fuller researched and
developed content for this episode with
additional research by jeff prickett
kendra gladdich is our production
coordinator and our executive producer
is tiffany steves with writing and
production from isabelle pillard and
andrew ganum and sound design and mixing
by alex bennett at lower street media
thanks for joining us we'll see you next
time
[Music]